[Music]
in a promise is a promise news submitted
by Fortune 'less cookie to him oh my god
I have one of those I felt raped man I
was like it's like a poem or something
it's not a fortune anymore yeah it's
just a cookie for reals it's a poem wait
what did wine the wine a lot
unfortunately cook is just without the
paper
yeah that's not thinking but I have my
own interpretation for that I wish you
could crack over the cookie it's just
like you are a piece of [ __ ] like a
company that makes like shit-talking
fortune cookie yeah it's like I want to
see somebody crack that open it's like
be across the room and see their
expression on the face like yeah I would
love that
oh you should make your own I would do
that choco fortune no you just call it
something nice like a fortune cookies or
something you know something that sounds
nicer and then it's all like you a piece
of [ __ ] looking [ __ ] you know I
love it your dad drove 20 you're you're
not your dad oh right hey did I miss
Lexington a um which is a bad thing I'm
getting a dad drove 20,000 miles on an
epic road trip to drop his daughter off
at college what's even $20 down
yeah dad 20 the u.s. is like 3,000 miles
oh [ __ ] really it's only 3,000 I think
it's you go to like Maine to San Diego
it's something more but not no point
where the [ __ ] did he come from the tip
of Chile all the way down to [ __ ]
North Pole some [ __ ] and then you got a
drive home this across the United States
twenty thousand right yeah then you got
to drive home wait from Costa cause it
can't be just 3,000 miles any more than
that maybe four or five it can't be sick
really I don't know it's not let's look
it up cuz it's like 400 miles or
something to Vegas right a few hundred
miles to Vegas no it's not 80 miles to
San Diego all right how wide is the
continental US it is 2802 miles
yeah cuz a flight from here to Texas is
like 1700 miles or something well that's
half way so this can't went from like
the end of Russia 200 sorry like the UK
or something or what from China all the
way to Washington how he swam since date
the absolute [ __ ] the car was like
driving through the ocean yeah yeah how
do you get through the Bering Strait did
you waited for the Ice Age yes uh dad
from China he had made his daughter a
promise a stupid promise
saying that he were cool long cuz you
get to see the world 20,000 miles pretty
stupid imagine seeing the world in a car
for very long time he probably special
vacation spent more money on getting
thousand on top of that he spent more
money on gas didn't like we'll see in 10
years it's about the experience how many
times did he change his tires and get a
wallet in the ground yeah I've had a
couple to change the batteries a couple
times got the car we do it every 5,000
miles right yeah sure if you listen to
their [ __ ]
I have 40,000 on my car and I haven't
done no okay and I ain't gonna because I
think it's a bunch of government
[ __ ] won't you government [ __ ]
that's what I think yeah so this epic
road trip took 108 days to complete a
third of a year
yep just to go to college or waste of
time no you freaking hypocrite it's not
the miles that got you maybe 30 days
well you think about it she's she's from
China right and she's going to
Washington collagen in here right or
Washington DC or Washington State yeah
so so they're probably not gonna see
each other like that much so he's kind
of like you're never like three
before like she can't just fly back you
know it's a couple months later they
could have had fun on the plane can you
tell me their route okay so they they
went through 26 countries they started
off on like the furthest east of China
okay I'll actually show you guys what's
really blurry but cuz if photos really
small yeah how'd it go look across the
Atlantic like that they drove all of
this they went through Russia all the
way around and then they ended up in the
UK and they took the Atlantic Bridge no
and then they took they flew into
Chicago and then they ship their car
over and then they how much did that
cost just gets pollen dude but then from
Chicago they drew they drove all the way
down to LA because I guess they wanted
to see LA well it's probably less than a
thousand bucks to ship the car over
because it costs me about five hundred
to ship a car over to Hawaii five
hundred but then what about across the
Atlantic is that more won't you rent a
car dude I don't know what I was giving
it to family members so yeah yeah so
here is the father and daughter
oh yeah the Toyota people last forever
that's why mm-hm
yeah Tacoma attendre
not sponsored that's pretty cool so this
isn't the first road trip that they did
a few years ago they took a road trip up
to the North Pole like the daughter took
a year off of school practice trip is a
dry run yeah [ __ ] North Pole four
years ago the daughter took an entire
year off the school and they traveled
across to the North Pole together and
then then that's when he said he made
her a promise saying that he'd drive her
to school she got accepted to a college
in the US and so when she got her
acceptance letter from a school in
Seattle
that's when immediately I started
planning out their road trip was the
North Pole like another bet I'll Drive
to the North Pole if you can [ __ ]
make this shot in the
but gambling a strange North Pole I know
you'd want to go to the North Pole there
Rose maybe from China you can go there
but rather go to Reno
I actually want to go to read and stay
at the water damage hotel which is every
hotel in Reno 100 - Mitchell Chen's like
all kind of run I've been there before
the best thing is winning it's like it's
like oh yeah like I'm an entertainer
it's like already view shows like Reno
what are you 67 yeah now that I've heard
that they'd do this thing this is the
second time doing this I think it's
pretty cool yes we - at the in his
article I thought they're just stupid
and during it for the first time but
this is something that how dear both of
you fun things have cynicism with me
please so he said this quote I thought
it was really cute he says after she
goes to college there won't really be
many opportunities in the future for me
to spend so much time with her she'll
have her own life so the least I could
do is send her on to the next chapter of
her life that's why she's not gonna have
that much time with her so that's like
there is a farewell gift because he
knows from this point on she's gonna be
partying getting plastered [ __ ] dudes
she's gonna go and she's gonna be
starting something college life girl
well most family members don't like them
don't like each other that much that's
how I was like you're making a big
mistake but they actually do like each
other that much so it works out had a
great time yeah I don't know you could
drive to the North Pole that shit's
really interesting because even really
loving family members will get cabin
fever after living together for like
they spent a hundred days - yeah that's
crazy in a car and a combined space like
this I feel like a road trip is like a
true test of like your relationship with
like your family members because it's
like to be in the car for that long and
to travel for that long you have to get
along fighting over radio stations yeah
our dude inconsistent bathroom schedules
yeah we're all going to bathroom right
now every one of us and then it's like
20 minutes later like I gotta go it's
like we just [ __ ] pulled
[Laughter]
you're right or do you think the worst
is like getting a lecture about like the
choices that you that you make in life
and just like non-stop talking until
they actually stop the car and you can
get okay
like for me I know I can't really do a
road trip with my parents because they
just drive me up the wall because like
[ __ ] wasting life with this JK new
stuff you know Julia you're you're a
girl you shouldn't be drinking cold
things cold things are so bad for your
body
oh I hate your mom already like she's
like tops off stuff that doesn't make
sense I was like close but like my
brother I was like but Ben can drink
cold water he's like yeah but he's a
dude I like that makes no sense a dude
can drink it but not me well if you
think about it that make sense you can
handle you can't handle your little girl
cold water really cool it's really cool
oh my god someone show your mom this
video wow there's the whole thing I'm
not gonna WWE video right now I'm like
wow I could hear your mom looking right
now going oh yeah Julia what the
argument was cold water not chugging a
lot of water yeah this one's cold water
that was [ __ ] impressive I have to
say that's just I mean you know Chinese
magic doesn't believe in sexism yeah
it's just it's just it's magic you're
even on the warrant
check my whole [ __ ] water you've got
all your germs you can't minor how do
they start this relationship today like
do baby steps like what starts the next
city over first where they just started
with the North Pole good question and
I'm not sure they just give give us a
whole broad scope of the story not
really details you know what though um I
I came from a very dysfunctional family
but on road trips it just took us out of
everything so it was like dope like we
would just be singing in a car listening
to stuff or like having deep ass
conversations for miles and miles and I
loved road trips because of that so I
have these cool memories where like I'm
not getting my ass beat or in trouble
we're just on our way to our destination
and it's really it was really fun so
maybe you know it's the same here where
like the road trips they take them out
of there every day
yeah like whatever maybe he's not
lecturing her they're just talking about
good memories and like it's like a fun
event because if I had that type of like
I can't stand being in the room with her
kind of relationship I don't think I
could do on a few days with my daughter
if that was I'd be by by the 50th day
I'm like we're flying [ __ ] 180 days
with anybody especially me well just
like you're cool with your dad right do
you think you can travel with them for
that long I don't know I've never been
in that situation I feel like it would
be pretty boring after the first couple
well I think it would be like this like
you'd be cool for like half a day and
then it'd be hella silent and good well
this is uh but then eventually you're
gonna figure out [ __ ] to talk about and
you're gonna really get closer to
someone it's kind of like you get over
that hump of the weirdness and then I
think you probably I think it's cute I
don't know any nose miles though but
there's there's they're probably
stopping a lot like I'm pretty sure they
planned out their trip and they're just
not like haulin ass and yeah so you're
stopping by and you're doing the tourism
so it's like you're stopping you're
checking out this doing that relaxing at
the resort for like three days and then
you go to a next place in the next place
so you're not constantly in the call
they're also that also means they like
using the same stuff to like to have
similar living habits where it becomes
enjoyable to have like a partner go with
you versus like just every stop is an
excuse to fight about something they
probably really get along because the
wife didn't come along and if she has
siblings they didn't come along yeah
what is the wife and the siblings yeah
there is no mention of wife or siblings
this daddy/daughter they probably are
very alike that's why they can they can
do it I could do this with my mom
because your mom yeah my mom my mom is
my mom my mom dude my mom is so
entertaining that she would spend like
if you get her talking like she'll get
to the point where she's like and
lizards control the government and
that's when I'm like oh it's a blast
dude but I love that [ __ ] you know
saying so much I'm just like and then
whatnot and then she's like well they
controlled it you know they control the
world and the Illuminati's and gets to
be a blast you know and I'm like hang on
I have to lose a control world then it
makes sense if you think about it so
yeah like help her out
why like we're cool with global warming
[ __ ] like making the earth harder
because the lizards want the [ __ ] has
to be hotter she's like that's exactly
right no this is just me like last week
no but it's for me it's like I'm
pitching her like underhanded softballs
like little league and just watching her
[ __ ] bail them out of the park and
like I get to watch everyone go out hey
guys I hope you enjoyed that episode of
just kidding news and if you did really
enjoy it or if you have thoughts about
what you just watched leave a comment
down below and let us know and for the
next video click right up here
[Music]